that's funny that they're racist to a
white guy that's such the opposite in
the Philippines like if Jorge went to
the Philippines and they would throw him
over their shoulder and like parade him
around town like like a [ __ ] prophet
you know like the white man always wins
in the Philippines for some Street hate
and what are we calling expats expats
expats they're the [ __ ] worst
why because you could or like I because
I spent two months in Thailand oh yes
you had nine year old white man walking
down the street with like a 19 year old
asian chick yeah holding hands it's
[ __ ] disgust but do you hate the
expats or let me tell you something in
the Philippines in the provincial area
they're told to be opportunistic they're
taught to be opportunistic so these
women it's it's sort of a used youth
situation if the man is using her trust
me when I say she's using him equally so
it's not it's it's it's mutually
beneficial in my eyes it might be a
little bit gross to us because we know
like that dirty old uncle is that's the
only place that he's gonna get laid
what is she gonna get out of it sucking
ET dick no she gets to comment with you
Derek and citizen she gets to migrate to
America or London or Australia it's just
gross
he supports her exactly and she gets to
now petition for her other family
members who didn't come over here and
work it's not her I'm not mad at her I
met at these 90 year old white dude
that's like what the [ __ ] what gives you
mean you don't [ __ ] you there's no
morality or you don't feel gross about
doing that I I don't think he should
feel gross because I think kalila is
right like everybody wins
everyone's getting what they want let me
ask you this then what is because we
think it's gross I was sort of a product
of that I mean not to say that like my
dear I am Buddhist of that well about 36
years older than my mother so from a
distance you would think that that's
exactly the situation at hand right yeah
but they were married for 22 years and
at you know perhaps she had a little bit
of an opportunistic you know intent in
the beginning but they did become
partners and they did raise my sister
and I really well 36 years yeah so she
was 20 60 yeah he was 60 when he just in
her to make me actually but actually I'm
30 and I imagine being with a
six-year-old and that's not that weird
yeah you have a match 20
and she was very well your boyfriend
your husband is now 60 now but when I do
think about being with a 60 year old man
like that's not so outlandish like I
could I could imagine it yeah Sam let me
ask you this in your work have you
worked with an older man yeah like how
old what's the oldest the oldest man
I've been with us probably not in porn
oh I see by in poor maybe was oldest
he's got a thing important with older
man with very young there is but I was
never very young in porn and I always
had fake tits so I never played like
that really oh yeah yeah but I mean I
mean like 60 probably is the oldest guy
in a porn wait they have a butt that's
why they call in a dedicated to that
they you like she's gonna break that up
I knew she was gonna break that it's
called old are they though you know good
bobbies are they like grandpa old yeah I
mean you know what it's for laughs
I don't think so wait yeah they're just
[ __ ] on these expats watches the
[ __ ] website about expat micelle
patron why okay this is some hella
hatred thing oh let's move on you know
what why you
[Music]